like so much else with kovid 19 the
latest figures on the uk
outbreak only confirm how little we know
every week the government's scientific
advisory group estimates the r number
the average number of people one
infected person will pass the virus onto
and like last week it's between 0.9
and 1.1 in other words the uk outbreak
could either be falling
rising or staying stable we don't quite
know
we also get regional r rates and again
there's a lot of uncertainty
in any of these areas the outbreak could
be shrinking
or growing the one exception is northern
ireland where the
r jumped recently although this is
skewed by low case numbers
and like all these r numbers it's the
data
is a bit old the basic issue is that a
low prevalence the r number is a very
fuzzy measure
and while it's important to monitor it
it doesn't tell us exactly what's going
on right now
so how else can we assess the state of
the uk outbreak
one of the best sources of information
is the office for national statistics
survey
which tests the same people week after
week and it shows that cases are still
low
in the week up to 20th of august an
estimated 28
200 people had coronavis that's only
around
one in 1900 people looking at the daily
case of coronavirus
you see it fell sharply after the
initial peak
got very low in june and then moved up a
bit before leveling off and that's where
we are now
but like the r number this data is a bit
old
and more importantly it's very general
if an outbreak starts
it won't begin everywhere it will begin
somewhere
these are the places that most risk
right now the blue areas
which represent the places currently
with the most infections per 100 000
people
and the key is identifying these
clusters and cutting them off before
they spread
with restrictions like the ones in place
here in these towns and cities in the
northwest
that is the most important thing right
now and we should focus on that
rather than worrying with the national r
number it's just above
or just below 1.